[Music]
right here's my question for you forget
as the best player like just as an offer
are you gonna challenge zebra this year
it looked like Kenny could be their man
he comes in from connector Oh has cover
and the quick shot burst of electronic
oh I don't care I just want to win how
do they manage from here the beat
offenders haven't moved at all oh and
they're out in the open up long a but
y'all fee never expected the road say
back at Kenny s is taking over triple
kill add some damage on to Sonny
probably deserved that one as well give
them four and if you ate it means that
I'm mighty good so if I'm worried good
that's enough for me playing some of the
best counter-strike we've seen Kenny s
play in many many years we knew him to
be one of the best players one of the
best AWP players to ever touch the game
he did really as well as you could
expect crepes look at it from Kenny to
stop flashes the ends of just
humiliated staring at the wall Kenny
he's looking for more and this is
phenomenal stuff is on those post boxes
he does drop in and Kenny he's doing it
all it's cash baby never forget the name
yes baby if you watch counter-strike you
already know who Kenny s is Flip rain on
the way in and Kenny you can see the arm
another frag broke he boosted it means
he knows where they're coming the
commitments on its way and Kenny he is
playing a suppliant game a
counter-strike today he's considered one
of Cisco's greatest players and for good
reason he innovated with the OP he hit
shots nobody else could and he's a major
champion on a second head show that play
me gonna be going here she marries
[Applause]
[Music]
and now eight years into his career
Kenny s is experiencing a renaissance
the OP God is balling out tournament
after tournament and g2 are considered
one of the best teams in the world in
this online era of Counter Strike
following a disappointing showing at the
2019 starladder berlin major shocks left
g2 to join CS goes other French squad
team vitality
[Music]
left with a vacant spot on their roster
g2 needed to find a replacement but
instead of sticking with a French lineup
g2 took a risk
welcome to ball 101
now that we're in g2 we're gonna teach
you guys about bombs so in came Nexon
hunter from crazy who replaced shocks
and lucky who was benched and that meant
that g2 needed to communicate in English
instead of French g2 pretty hot to trot
and look at look at them they've just
been waiting around yeah I have a sweet
spot for cheaters there's no need for me
to lie about it I think we have to
realize how huge of a change and a risk
they took nine months ago remember they
changed from the full french-speaking
roster to an english-speaking roster
bringing in next and hunter and at the
time that was gigantic what kind of a
risk was that I was a huge shift of
paradigmatic to approach counter-strike
somebody were doubting him I wasn't sure
this is gonna work but when you look at
the results they've had now they can
stay now they can say they had the right
idea like many new rosters this new
international g2 needed time to gel
there are tournaments in late 2019
weren't that great become 2020 and there
was real potential in this team g2
kicked off the new year by topping their
group at blast premier spring which
featured top teams like a hundred
thieves and eg but after blast g2 made a
fantastic run at IEM katowice and Kenny
s made the tournament's grand finals for
the first time in his career that is
that's a strong message sent here g2
incredibly powerful and Kenny what a
must feel like for him to be in the
grand finals it's the first time Kenny s
has actually played on the SPO Dec stage
the first time he's made it into the
playoffs and he's in the grand finals
he's got a chance at this trophy a
chance to get his name on the trophy on
his just his very first attempt and it's
such a deserving opportunity for a
legend such as Kenny s sure g2 didn't
win Katowice
but Kenny s had a monster performance
throughout the tournament and this guy
hasn't stopped
he's been playing nuts later on us knew
somebody they will have a reinvestment
twice Oh God immediately Kenny is quick
he's not even looking at him and he's
still firing off the kills ball for
Kenny
blinkin you missed this round he's done
but he couldn't do it alone
his teammates both old and new have
stepped up big time lately and added
that necessary firepower in order to
back up the French superstar Jax is on
his own and they know exactly where he
is he's trying to escape trying to
reposition just to make it a little bit
tricky but he's gonna have to get at
least two more kills here before this
round is even close and this one of them
hiding inside the smoke here genius he's
taken down the searcher and now the
pistols out what a god-like play from
Jackson he's still baiting them out the
only knock against this version of g2
seems to be their tendency to choke
despite placing high at every tournament
they've played in this year g2 hasn't
won yet they've lost three grand finals
in a row most recently big reverse swept
them to take Dreamhack masters that is a
big they take this series they take the
final and they secured the championship
run the reverse sweep they do it in
overtime but despite not winning g2 s
consistent top placings have earned them
the number one spot on the hltv rankings
for g2 the focus now is getting over
that grand finals hump to finally win
that next big offline tournament
whenever that is and to be crowned
champions and thankfully for them they
have a living legend who knows how to do
exactly that thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]